Transcriber: Ayça Melis Aysel
Gözden geçirme: Ilayda Gokgoz
Herkese merhabalar ben Seren Anaçoğlu.
20 yasındayım bir iklim aktivistiyim
ve bugün de benim mottom olan ″İklim krizi
bir insan hakları problemidir″
sözüyle sunuma başlayacağım.
Ben şu an Bahçeşehir Üniversitesinde
Hukuk Fakültesi öğrencisiyim.
Birinci sınıfım.
Aynı zamanda Kabataş Erkek
Lisesi mezunuyum.
Zaten hikayem de Kabataş Erkek
Lisesi’ne girmemle başladı.
Çünkü son sınıftayken Avrupa Birliği
tarafından iklim elçisi seçildim.
Aynı zamanda bir derneğin kurucu üyesiyim
ve şu anda çevreyle ilgili bir şirkette
ürün geliştirme uzmanı
olarak çalışıyorum.
Şimdi iklim aktivisti nasıl oldum,
nasıl bir iklim elçisi oldum
size bunlardan bahsedeceğim öncelikle.
Şöyle, küçükken hep bir fırsatım oldu,
hep büyüklerim ile büyüdüm, büyüklerim
beni yetiştirdi ve bunu fark ettim ki
büyüklerimin söylediği şeyleri hep bir
kenara atarken işte suyu
tasarruflu kullan,
suyu kullandıktan sonra kalan
suyu bitkilere döküyordu
anneannem, babaannem bu yüzden hep böyle
dikkatimi çekiyordu yaptıkları
ama hiç bir zaman kendim uygulamayı
düşünmemiştim.
Çünkü daha çok küçüktüm, 11 12
yaşlarındaydım ve gördükten sonra bana
hep bunları söylüyorlardı,
uyarıyorlardı beni.
Ben de hep böyle şey diyordum işte
ya siz niye bunları anlatıyorsunuz ki,
bu ne işe yarayacak
diye böyle bir kenara bırakıyordum
aslında dinlemiyordum.
Sonrasında 2019 senesinde şunu gördüm
İstanbul'da, Ankara'da, Bursa'da
barajların doluluk oranlarının ne kadar
düşük olduğunu gördüm ve bütün haberler
şunu söylüyordu İstanbul'da yüzde 9
doluluk oranı ve İstanbul’a yetmeyecek.
Nasıl yapmalıyız?
İşte Büyükşehir Belediyesi insanlara
musluk başlığı dağıtıyordu ki daha
verimli kullanabilsinler suyu diye
ve dedim ki bu çok önemli bir problem.
Eğer büyüklerimiz bu yokluğu
biliyorsa buna göre hareket edip
tasarruf edebiliyorlarsa
biz niye yapmıyoruz?
Biz niye bunu okullarda daha
fazla anlatmıyoruz?
Niye bunu bir hayat felsefesi olarak
göstermiyoruz diye düşünüp duruyordum.
Müfredatın yetersiz olduğunu görüyordum.
Hükümetin yaptıklarının yetersiz olduğunu
görüyordum ve bir şekilde
ben nasıl harekete geçebilirim
diye düşünmeye başladım.
Ve sonra 22 Nisan Dünya Günü'nü gördüm.
2019 senesinde ve 22 Nisan Dünya
Günü dünyaya sarılma günüymüş.
Dünyanın varlıklarını korumakla ilgili
aslında bir anma günüymüş
ve bunu gördükten sonra dedim ki
ben ne yapabilirim? dedim.
Kabataş Erkek Lisesi’nde Çevre
Kulübü’nün başkanı seçildim.
Kendi yaptığım projem sayesinde.
Ve sonra kulübe girdikten sonra oradaki
arkadaşlarımın Greta’nında başlattığı
bir hareket olan Fridays for Future
hareketine dahil oldum.
İklim İçin Türkiye ve Youth For Climate’da
bunların Türkiye’de kurulmuş versiyonu.
2019 senesinden beri Türkiye'de iklim
hareketleri düzenleniyor ve ben de bu
etkinin bir parçası oldum.
Ve sonra kendime ben artık bir iklim
aktivistiyim, iklim krizi için mücadele
edeceğim hareketiyle ben
de onlara dahil oldum.
Sonrasında tabi ki hayatımda çok
büyük değişiklikler oldu.
İklim Elçisi seçildim, Avrupa Birliği'nde
konferanslara katıldım, yurtdışındaki
bakış açısını görme fırsatını elde ettim.
Çünkü Avrupa Birliği gerçekten iklim krizi
için mücadele ediyor, insanların
gerçek, iyi bir geleceğe sahip
olması için mücadele ediyor.
Plastik kullanımını yasaklıyorlar,
tarımın nasıl daha verimli
olabileceğini anlatıyorlar.
Ve ben de bu bakışı Türkiye'ye
kazandırmaya çalışan insanlardan biriyim.
Aynı zamanda her sene iklim grevleri
düzenliyoruz ve
bu görevlerde bizimle beraber eşlik
eden binlerce kişi oluyor.
Basın açıklaması okuyoruz mesela bizim
grevlerimizden sonra Türkiye, Paris
Anlaşması’nı imzalamayı
kabul etti tekrardan.
Bence biz bu hareketlerle bir
şeyleri değiştirebiliyoruz.
Ben de bunu gördüm.
Çünkü bizim yalnız olmadığımızı görüyorlar
Bizim 7'den 70'e yüzlerce genç bir araya
geldiğimizde bunları yapabildiğimizi
görüyorlar ve biz normal bir şey
için mücadele etmiyoruz.
Kendi geleceğimiz için mücadele ediyoruz.
Şimdi gelelim iklim krizi
neden bir insan hakları problemi.
İklim krizinden dolayı
2050 senesine kadar
bir milyar insanın evinden olacağı
yani göç edeceği düşünülüyor.
Bu çok büyük bir rakam.
1 milyar insan evlerinden olacak, belki
işlerinden olacak, belki okullarına
gidemeyecek, belki sırf bu göç
zamanında hayatlarını kaybedecek.
Tabii ki bunu 2050 senesi, ne kadar
uzak, diye düşünmeyelim.
Çünkü şu an bile her sene 300′den fazla
çok büyük doğa felaketi meydana geliyor.
Türkiye'de bunu görüyoruz.
Türkiye’de farkındasınızdır, bir gün
hava çok farklı oluyor,
bir gün çok farklı oluyor.
Biz artık bunları eskiden daha nadir
yaşıyorken, son yüz elli senedir sanayi
devriminden itibaren hem karbon
emisyonunun artışıyla
sanayileşmenin, kapitalizmin artışıyla
birlikte
bunu daha fazla yaşamaya başladık.
Bu hava felaketlerini artık haftada bir,
belki haftada 2 yaşamaya başladık.
Ve bu felaketlerden dolayı binlerce
insan hayatını kaybediyor.
İnsan hakları, dünyanın olmadığı,
gezegenin gerçekten kirlendiği ve
oksijenin kirlendiği bir
ortamda yaşanamaz.
Çünkü insanların öldüğü bir yerde
insan hakları da olmaz.
Burada gördüğünüz kız okula
gitmeye çalışıyor.
Orada deniz seviyesi o kadar
yükselmiş
veya sel felaketleri o kadar fazla
yaşanıyor ki
bu kız okuluna gitmeye çalışıyor,
bu yoldan gitmeye çalışıyor.
Sadece bunu yurtdışında değil Türkiye'de
de görmekteyiz biliyorsunuz ki.
Hatta bu güzel bir örnek.
Çünkü okuluna gidebiliyor.
Ama belki bu yüzden okuluna gidemeyen
o kadar fazla çocuk var ki.
Burada da biraz kendimizi düşünelim.
Nasıl eve gidiyoruz, okulumuza gidiyoruz
ya da işlerimize gidiyoruz,
arabamız oluyor, toplu taşımayla
gidebiliyoruz ve hani belki de
iyi koşullarda yaşıyoruz diyebiliriz
kendi hayatlarımızda.
Ama bu insanlar Bangladeş'te bu şekilde
hayatlarını sürdürmeye çalışıyorlar.
Küçücük bir tekneye
5, 6 kişi sığmaya çalışıp
bu şekilde evlerine gitmeye çalışıyorlar.
Ne kadar kötü görebiliyorsunuz değil mi?
Bu da aslında yurt dışından
bir örnek değil maalesef.
Marmaris’ten bir görüntü.
Burada sizin biraz da incelemenizi
istiyorum bu görüntüyü.
Çünkü biz tüm ülkece
bunu belki günlerce
uyku uymayarak, belki aylarca yüzümüz
gülmeyerek karşıladık.
Ben açıkcası kendim uyuyamadım.
orman yangınları yaşandığından beri.
Marmaris’te yaşanan orman yangınlarında
gerçekten birçok köy telef oldu.
Birçok köylü işinden, çiftliğinden,
evinden oldu, kasabasından oldu.
Hepsi göç etmek zorunda kaldı.
Bu yüzden iklim krizinin çok büyük
bir problem olduğunun
farkına varmamız gerekiyor.
Bu da Antalya’da bir görüntü.
Elmalı’da bir görüntü.
Bu da bir sel felaketinden
alınmış bir görüntü.
Ama biliyorsunuz ki Kahramanmaraş’ta da
yakın zamanlarda
çok büyük bir sel felaketi görüldü.
Ve biz buna önlem almadığımız için birçok
insan da insan haklarından
faydalanamadı.
Çünkü bunun önlemi alınamadı.
Çünkü bunun durdurulması için
bir şey yapılmadı.
Şimdi gelelim çocuk haklarından bahsettik.
Belki biraz insan haklarından bahsettik
ama özellikle de kadın haklarını
vurgulamak istiyorum.
Hepsini tabii ki tek bir çatı
altında görmemiz gerekiyor
ama tabii ki hava felaketlerinin en çok
yaşandığı bölgelerde, en çok etkilenen
kesimde kadınlar ve çocuklar oluyor.
Kadınlar da şu şekilde etkileniyorlar.
Eşleri başka kasabaya çalışmaya gittiği
için kendileri çocuklarına
bakmak durumunda kalıyor.
Kendileri, belki o suları temizlemek,
evlerindeki suları,
yükselen suları temizlemek
durumunda bırakılıyor
ve bu yüzden de belki sağlıklarından
belki de yaşamlarından oluyorlar.
Aynı zamanda şurda gördüğünüz görüntü,
küçük çocukların evlendirilme sahnesi.
Bu gerçek bir görüntü.
Bu o kadar kötü ki, sırf bu felaketlerden
etkilenmesin diye daha iyi bir aileye
belki benden küçük çocuklar evlendirilmek
durumunda bırakılıyor.
O kadar kötü ki gerçekten.
Ben bunu ilk okuduğumda o kadar
etkilenmiştim, o kadar gözlerim
dolmuştu ki nasıl bunu
yapabiliyorlar demiştim.
Doğayla savaş halindeyiz.
Kazanırsak kaybedeceğiz.
Bu sözü unutmayın.
Şimdi gelelim iklim krizini
nasıl çözebiliriz.
Probleme odaklandık.
Şimdi de çözümünü odaklanmamız gerekiyor.
Aslında başta nedenlerinden bahsetmem
gerekirse iklim krizinin
oluşmasında o en büyük neden de fosil
yakıtların kullanılıyor olması.
Dediğim gibi 150 senedir maksimum
değişikliğe uğradı hava sıcaklığı
dünyanın sıcaklığı
ve sırf bunların en büyük kaynaklarından
biri de fosil yakıtların kullanılıyor
ve üretiliyor olması.
Avrupa Birliği bunun için çok
büyük uğraş içerisinde.
Sürdürülebilir enerjiye geçmek için
çok büyük uğraşlar içerisinde.
Ve başka bir konu da plastik kullanımı.
Plastik kullanımının ne kadar fazla
canlıyı etkilediğini düşündüğümüzde
gerçekten hayretler içinde kalabiliyoruz.
Belki görmüşsünüzdür martının
ayakları takılıyor, attığımız plastikler
sakızlardan dolayı ölüyorlar
falan derken
bir yandan da plastik adaları var.
Yedinci Kıta diye bir ada var ve
Türkiye'nin üç katı büyüklüğünde plastik
atıklarının birleştiği bir ada
ve okyanusları kirletiyor.
Okyanuslar kirlendiğinde okyanusların
asitliği değişiyor.
İşte kutupların erimelerini biliyorsunuz.
Kutuplardaki deniz yükselmelerini
biliyorsunuz
Birçok ülkenin ve adanın bu su
yüksekliğinden dolayı kaybolacağı da
öngörülüyor şu an.
Aslında bundaki tek çare yenilenebilir
enerjiye geçmek.
Yenilenebilir enerji gerçekten
hem karbon emisyonunu minimum orana
düşürecek hem de iklim krizine belki de
nötrleyecek diyebiliriz.
Bu da benim aslında
bireysel olarak yaptıklarımın dışında
hükümete nasıl erişebilirim,
şirket yöneticilerine nasıl
erişebilirim diye
arkadaşlarımla yaptığımız
eylemlerden iki tanesi
ve burada gerçekten işte
size okumak istiyorum.
Mesela termik santralle ilgili
pankartlarımız var,
kuzey ormanlarıyla ilgili
pankartlarımız var.
Çünkü biliyorsunuz köprüler,
binalar yapılırken ne kadar
fazla ağaç kesiliyor.
Üçüncü köprü yapılırken bir milyon
tane ağacın kesildiğini
Bilmiyorsunuz.
O yüzden Kuzey Ormanları
Savunması deniyor.
İklim krizini çözmek durumundayız.
Çözmek zorundayız.
Bu yüzden de hepimizin hem bireysel olarak
hem de kollektif bir hareket
içerisinde bununla mücadele etmemiz
gerektiğini bilmesi gerekiyor.
Beni dinlediğiniz için
çok teşekkür ederim.
(Alkış)